gutefrage.net real talk damals hat mir
diese website bei fast jedem problem
geholfen egal ob es auf die schule
bezogen war oder auf sport fußballverein
oder auch freunde oder auf
gesundheitliche sachen ich bin immer
schlussendlich auf dieser website
gelandet wo mir irgendwelche leute die
absolut keine vorkenntnisse hatten
weitergeholfen haben ich habe husten was
könnte das sein
krebs jedoch wurde auch schon damals
diese website für eine menge schwachsinn
missbraucht von da habe ich mir gedacht
schauen wir uns heute mal ein paar dumme
fragen und antworten dort an
wie zum beispiel die hier findet ihr
trinken oder rauchen cooler beides
extremen lässige dinge hallo wenn ihr
ein mädchen beeindrucken wollen würdet
und cool tun wollt findet ihr es als
mädchen cooler wenn man raucht oder
trinkt
also es ist ja logischerweise eine was
er frage also wir müssen uns entscheiden
von daher würde ich eher trinken nehmen
ein schönes wasser kann ja auch schön
vibrieren warum entsteht stau ich mein
fahrrad auch einfach warum bleibst du
stehen oder bremst man sich keine so
verkehrte frage weil bei einem
reißverschlussverfahren wenn sich alle
perfekt daran halten würden dass man die
spur bis zum ende fährt am einordnen
reinlassen blabla gar kein ding
irgendetwas passiert ist einfach daran
vorbeifahren nicht irgendwie auf 30 km/h
abbremsen und gucken wie so ein gaffer
oder so aber manchmal eine vollsperrung
ist oder eine rote ampel dann kann man
halt nicht fahren also da ist die frage
dann wiederum ein bisschen doof haye
wird es jetzt mehr übergewichtige als
sonst geben lebensmittelpreise sind ja
gestiegen und dann halt auch noch eine
abstimmung wo die meisten leute für
stimmt abgestimmt haben
dies ergibt noch gar kein seemann
lebensmittelpreise steigen kaufen noch
tendenziell eher weniger leute irgendwas
ein und dann jedoch also müsst justiz
jobs mit zwei daumen hoch
was in welchem bundesland in usa ist
albuquerque von breaking bad
ja das ist ein profil name sagt
eigentlich schon alles der eroberer 1
geht die zeit schnell von ca 8 bis 14
uhr herr
die zeit geht immer gleich stellt das
hat dieser user allerdings nicht so ganz
verstanden denn in seiner nächsten frage
fragt er dann geht die zeit von 8 bis 12
schnell um und er hat natürlich
selbstverständlich auch noch eine dritte
frage in der herr gedonnert und zwar
findet ihr die zeit geht schnell von 8
bis 16 uhr 12 us pause
ich glaub das war so ein kind was damals
an so ein praktikum hatten sich dann so
gedacht hat boa ich will doch wieder
zurück in der schule die die zeit so
oder so schneller um ist es komisch wenn
man manchmal mit seinen eltern in die
vorlesung geht
also wenn jetzt ein kindergarten
geschrieben hat ist okay
obwohl wahrscheinlich nicht mal
schreiben wozu ein deo hallo ich habe
deine frage ich habe bisher noch nie ein
deo benutzt weil ich nicht genau wusste
wozu man das braucht aber in letzter
zeit stinken männer achseln heißt das
dass ich jetzt im alter bin um ein deo
zu benutzen und wenn ja zu welchen
zeiten sollte man es benutzen
kann ich will ich gar nichts gemein ist
sagen weil das kann uns glaube ich alle
irgendwann mal gefragt irgendwann geht's
los in der pubertät mit calado um 13 14
15 und 16 dass man anfängt zu stinken
und dann kauft man sich in so ein axa
alaska de oder dach hat früher jede
umkleidekabine von uns nur sporthalle
gerochen und sprüht sie das unter die
achseln dann geht's auch aus mit pickeln
und deine stimme verändert sich es sind
ganz normale sachen und die frage ist
eigentlich auch relativ normal wo ich
jetzt im endeffekt zu müssen weiter
darüber nachdenke habe ich große
hasenzähne kann man das korrigieren oder
wegfallen mit einer nagelfeile
und dieses bild hängt er noch an
wenn montana black von diesen szenen zu
diesen szenen gekommen ist dann wirst du
das auch irgendwie hinkriegen tab
autobahnpolizei verarscht schlimm
fragezeichen die wollten mich anhalten
weil ich zu schnell oder zu dicht
gefahren bin und sind dann vor mir
gekommen
alles klar und da stand folgen oder
bitte folgen eine ausfahrt sind dann
runter und ich begreife geradeaus beide
sänger auch gefeiert denn es gibt eine
hohe strafe kann ja sagen dass sie angst
hatte dass das nicht richtige polizisten
sind oder
das gibt tatsächlich dann irgendwie doch
richtige strafe glaube ich seid ihr
gerne dick
sachen die auf dieser website gefunden
wurden würdet ihr gerne menschen
probieren das fleisch
ich habe mal gehört dass das so
schmecken soll wie känguru fleisch
und ich hab noch nie kennen vielleicht
gegessen aber da habe ich auch schon mal
drüber gehört dass das schmecken soll
wie eine schuhsohle
ich glaube ich würde eher ungern
menschen verspüren wenn westen aus
versehenen die bahn fliegen und ihr
heimatort 2,8 kilometer weit entfernt
liegt finden sie dann aus 2,8 kilometern
entfernung wieder zurück nach hause das
ist eine gute frage ich euch mal vorne
westen fliegt irgendwie in die bahn ryan
dunn gehen baden können einfach zu
machen wir dann in münchen einsteigt in
berlin wieder raus das komplett
kulturschock wieso ist das so man
erwartet jetzt vielleicht irgendeine
physikalische biologische chemie frage
oder sohn ein
warum haben die youtuber mit den meisten
klicks über die sozialsten introns
kinder schreien und im hintergrund
polizeisirene jojo es ist euer
birkenstock was die glocke und aber
ich sag einfach hallo mein name ist luca
vielleicht sollte ich mir jetzt auch mal
polizei sie reden und irgendwie ja und
hintergrund packen die alt seid ihr nur
so und wieso seid ihr auf dieser website
ist es interessant
wird ob ich hätte gern dein maß an
langeweile erstes date night hallo ich
habe immer eine frage gestellt dass ich
eine freundin suche und jetzt habe ich
morgen einen date und ich weiß nicht was
wir machen wollen denkt ihr es ist
komisch sich beim ersten date im disco
zu treffen und fordern zu zocken oder
denkt ihr dass sie es cool findet naja
ich glaube er nicht wollte ein mann auch
manchmal aggressiv sein und schreien
weil wenn man immer gechillt und
gelassen ist zeigt was wenig
männlichkeit
stimmt nicht
wer da anderer meinung
allerdings gerade beim thema android
sind meine lieben freunde was ist die
beste schulnote um mädchen zu
beeindrucken hallo schlechtere noten im
bereich von 4 bis 6 sind ja dafür da um
cool zu wirken wobei vier die beste note
ist da man cool ist und das klassenziel
erreicht ich habe aber kürzlich android
entdeckt und er sagte der mann soll in
allem besser sein als die frau deshalb
überlege ich ob ich von nun an nur noch
ein satz schreiben soll was meint ihr
dazu wollt ihr mädels er coole leute
oder stimmt die android aids these zu
wenn jesus noch leben würde wie alt wäre
er
warum schon einmal welches jahr wir
aktuell haben warum ist es schwul als
junge schrägstrich man alleine eis essen
zu gehen mein cousin der gerade mal zehn
ist hat letztes gesagt dass ich schwul
ist als junger eis essen zu gehen was
ist daran schwulen her ganz klar dass
ein
ultra schwul geht garnicht ansgar schlei
warum steht man auf ältere frauen zum
beispiel zwölf jahre
das heißt die person die das geschrieben
hat es unter 12
warum hast du ein handy parade ja eh
schon eins hast kannst du gerne dem
video einen daumen hoch da lassen ein
kanal abonnieren und auf die glocke
klicken dann kommen die benachrichtigung
auf ihr handy seit mai ist wieder online
geht
hoeneß popstar das handy mit festhält
und cooler smiley darauf gibt es die
[Musik]